e
en 1957 chargé de mission pour six mois
en ardèche
mademoiselle nicholas est tellement
attaché au pays à ses habitants qu'elle
y est encore depuis 15 ans elle poursuit
relents travail quotidien pour réanimer
ces régions montagnardes déshérités
vous avez emporté du travail faut bien
de travailler ces demoiselles nicolas il
vous fait ça oui c'est pour l'arizona
alors il vous big être la famille bich
est dès qu'elle me voit pas si elles
viennent avec moi j'ai l'impression
regarder elles sont en train de regarder
oui oui elle me suivent je me suis avait
démarré sa ya 14 ans et ma nouvelle
nicolas oui vous êtes le premier en
somme et oui je t'aime qui est du genre
à me touche entrée l'artisanat donc est
un artisanat particulier qu'on appelle
l'art paysans lard paysan et tente une
reprise des techniques anciennes rural
partant du matériau paysans pas ici
rocla caillou brûle classé noble laine
soie et le transformant pour un usage
personnel
alors l'artisanat était pour eux à la
fois un moyenne création donc un moyen
de faire marcher leur cerveau puis un
moyen d'avoir un contact avec
l'extérieur
j'ai toujours appris aux paysans de ne
pas se considérer comme des artistes
nous n'avons pas de sculpteurs l'ardèche
est très pauvre
c'est un moyen d'expression surtout
c'est beau parce que ce sont des formes
simples sont les gens très simples
justement qui ont réappris à s'exprimer
thèse qui sont sans histoire sans
snobisme et ils transmettent quelque
chose qui n'existe plus tellement à
l'heure actuelle s'il ya quelque chose
de vrai
les compagnons du jer bull ce sont ces
paysans ardéchois qui se repliait de
plus en plus sur eux-mêmes car il ne
voyait plus l'utilité de leur
agriculture est acquis l'artisanat
apporte des ressources supplémentaires
mais aussi des contacts des échanges
ils ont créé ou retrouver des modèles
dont ils sont considérés comme les
inventeurs et qu'est ce que cela leur
rapporte et bien le smic pendant les
quatre mois d'hiver où les travaux
agricoles sont ralenties cela semble peu
c'est parfois beaucoup dans les régions
montagnardes très pur où il habite
oui oui mais vous aviez appris comment à
faire cela vous le savez vous pas peur
elle en fait j'ai quelques know who mais
sûrement que cette activité vous amène à
voir plus de monde que vous n'en voyez
avant les fleuristes fameux bruit vous
les voyez encore certains biens propres
mots pour moi je trouvais ça tombe bien
pour la commune quoi mais oui sûrement
on voit des jeunes voir les voitures et
s'assistent est un peu amènes dit pas ça
jean même pas l'ombre ainsi leur commune
j'ai bien peur que de dieu
monsieur et madame dubois vivent dans
ces vieilles fermes près de tin entourée
d'énormes rochers de châtaignier ils y
vivent seuls tous les deux
la maison est magnifique jeu de cour
d'escalier de dépendance sur les
vieillards robinet avec l'eau courante
mais c'est l'eau du torrent qui descend
de la montagne
il faisait très chaud
toutes les heures la danse est leur part
tout cas ça me tire tout le temps c'est
curieux mais les abeilles dans 10 à 15
tonnes habituellement pique pas que je
n'y a pas manière il ya professeur
marges
qu'est ce que ça fait une russie a fait
combien de miel par an va l'entendre
qu'il au travail et l'eau est douce
nous y sommes allés la verrue sur la
barre c'est pas pour moi un paysan
devrait aussi savoir se poser cette
question maintenant qu'il a pris
l'habitude de prendre du recul
la société a besoin de notre région en a
plus besoin pour son blé puisque ce
n'est pas rentable ni pour savine mais
pourquoi en at elle besoin là on a
besoin pour sa beauté son calme sa
solitude même sans retrouver la
dimension humaine
te
la pauvreté a épargné la région des
leaders du citadin qui installe qu'une
résidence secondaire le font bien car la
rigueur la beauté du pays attire les
exigeants les purs dans les vallées
fruitière plus riches les maisons sont
plus importantes splendide flanqué
encore des magnaneries où l'on traite
elle vers à soie comme ici chez les
rochers près des vans ou cohabitent de
trois générations
1797 c'est pas d'hier et satyanand ça je
suis pas d hier il ya un moment que ça
élève est sûr c'est que pour faire des
maisons comme ça ils devaient travailler
moment je ne risque pas été fait tout le
même jour bien sûr ça on voit bien ça a
été ajouté d'un côté ou de l'autre et
vous l'aimez cette maison ma foi on y
est les il faudra bien y mourir
rester ici à vie
qu'est ce qui vous plaît ici c'est la
liberté vaut bien bas puis ce métier qui
me plaît est ce que vous êtes consciente
que vous avez une très très très belle
maison des mots forts nous le dit
maintenant
l'intermédiaire pense quoi lancer pas
trop comment faire on peut le mieux
conservé par dylan tient pas pour la
rénover la maison surtout l'extérieur
voudriez conserver l'aspect extérieur
anciens et oui et puis on peut me dire
de la mer pour être homme c'est bien il
faut quand même un peu de l'utile de
confort en tout cas pas comment le
placer neri pour pabu et la maison
intérieur et extérieur aussi servi à
quoi ce balcon à leur extérieur la filer
dans le talk au corps alors chaque mois
ou presque avec sochaux pour viser quoi
il y avait 1
petits fours quoi puis le bassin dessus
pour mettre les bords avec un balai puis
ramasser tous les fils que ça ne fait
qu'un an après qui s'envole après ordre
et je n'ai pas vu faire la voix des
verts je sais mon père m'a raconté ce
fils et là vous me disiez madame que
finalement ça vous énerver un petit peu
tous ces gens qui disaient à ce que vous
êtes bien ce que c'est joli et c'est au
début m en moyenne au début maintenant
au début quand les gens arrivent et qui
me dira oh mon dieu que tu gagnes ici
madame vous avez tout ça alors moi ça
m'ennuyait de dire
why me semble qu ailleurs et on était
venu ici alors qu'est-ce que vous avez
ici maintenant à votre avis qu'est-ce
que vous avez bien ici la tranquillité
aux noirs aux labos nom et le bonnet un
foyer pas que ces trois champs de
valable mais je comprends et surtout
pour mon mari alors vous êtes heureux ou
malheureux là tous les deux voilà notre
famille on y sera la mise
je lui préfère habiter la ville vous pas
d'amis performant dylan et le même pas
loin d'un 10 km dames y sommes pas loin
et même maintenant un mouvement de
panique comme ça alors ça fait combien
de temps vous le suivez je vous ai dit
il ya quand même des mariés on va très
bien dont cinq en colère de dieu vous
vivez la longueur d'année madame sonia
toute la nuit
c'est pas trop dur l'hiver et l'été
nous voyons un peu trop de mots il y en
a presque 30 le petit village consomme
oui vraiment puis certaines
journet sais c'est dur parce que
vraiment les touristes sont pénibles
qu'est ce qui fonde mal à qui l'on pense
tous ceux qui tournent même les lauzes
les pierres savez qu'est ce que c'est
qu'un étranger à fournir à l'étranger
pour nous tous qui viennent dans le pays
ils ne sont pas de la région jusqu'où la
jab de l'ardèche et encore et encore
mais pas du côté des vases pas plus que
dans trois kilomètres alentour des deux
teen on est on est pas un étranger non
quand même pas mais après ah bah oui on
est on les prend pour des étrangers
elle aura touristes c'est un étranger
avait oui on considère le common
étrangers oui on le considère on échange
et c'est à dire qu'au départ faut quand
même se méfier il y en a on est obligé
de se méfier parce que vraiment eux
aussi se méfier de nous quel caractère
des gens du coin la défense dans son
camp des caractères différents suivant
les régions mais dans la région de deux
teen particulièrement les cévennes les
gens sont de véritables petits
aristocrate ils sont propriétaires de
leur terrain depuis quinze censé se sent
presque tous sont des documents qui
prouvent qu'ils sont libres depuis très
très longtemps ils n'ont jamais esclaves
mini se sont jamais donné non plus à
personne
un tempérament assez intéressant c'est
unique même en france dans le monde
paysan un tempérament du rossi qui
n'admet pas qu'on transmette leurs
petites histoires qu'ils défendent entre
eux qu'ils se bouffent entre eux aussi
enfin c'était ça aussi que les fendre
quand il ya une histoire par exemple
c'est difficile de donner des 6 et 6,5
un peu lointain alors de lui faire des
choses